en tout cas quand je vois à quoi ça mène
un handicapé qui a de l'argent moi
j'arrête de donner au Téléthon quoi
c'est
je plaisante j'ai jamais donné
le meilleur de Gaspard Proust de
nombreux messages m'ont été adressés
suite à la dernière chronique dont un
très intéressant merci pour ce coup de
poignard au cœur que des milliers de
parents de victimes et de victimes de
pédophiles ont dû recevoir ce soir
devant votre édito à quand un édito sur
le viol collectif le lynchage raciste le
massacre des enfants en Syrie alors je
tenais à remercier cette personne pour
ses idées de thème que je vous propose
de développer sans plus attendre
le lâchage raciste chaque jour en France
des gens mangent des pains au chocolat
viol collectif ne vous arrêtons pas ce
terme d'un autre œil si on se contentait
de parler d'amour participatif
en ce qui concerne le massacre des
enfants en Syrie alors là c'est un petit
problème impossible de s'en moquer
puisque à l'heure où je vous parle on
peut se demander s'il reste encore des
enfants en Syrie
l'international nous fournit
régulièrement son lot de macchabée
ouverture de la tombe d'Arafat
quelle folie ne jamais décongeler de la
viande halal
après le gigot de 7 heures l'Arafat de 2
ans
tout ça pour voir s'il n'a pas été farci
au plutonium c'est vrai que l'avantage
s'ils en trouve c'est qu'ils pour
toujours envoyer la dépouille en Iran
pour qu'il enrichissent leur bombe
je propose des choses voilà c'est ça il
faut essayer
Tunisie
incarcéré pour sodomie c'est quand même
sympa la justice tunisienne quoi on
condamne un type pour un acte auquel il
pourra s'adonner librement en prison
[Applaudissements]
tu auras pas ton adresse
je te mot alors le grand rabbin de
France Gilbert et Naïm déjà coupable de
plagiat a en plus usurpé son agreg de
philo ça manque plus qu'on découvre
qu'il organisait des soirées jambon
rillettes avec Tariq Ramadan
[Applaudissements]
décès il nous a quitté ce grand musicien
qui a profondément marqué la vie des
français par son sens de la ritournelle
je veux parler de Jeff an man le
guitariste de Slayer alors Slayer c'est
un groupe extraordinaire c'est vraiment
pas de la musique de enfin pour tous
quoi
[Rires]
mais en train de se faire violer
c'est
amour Jean-François Copé veut
reconstruire une relation affective avec
les Français non ça c'est au rayon
humour pardon
amour toujours
DSK aurait essayé d'embrasser une
journaliste italienne à la fin des
années 90 DSK il est plus fort que la
drogue du violeur avec lui les victimes
se réveillent 10 ans après quoi
plus que 5 ans et un de Saint Clair pour
te plainte pour mariage forcé tu vois
plomberie
Oscar Pistorius
[Applaudissements]
le type qui est monté sur des lattes de
sommier
un Pistorius moi la première fois que je
l'ai vu courir on dirait un nain qui
fait du trampoline
en tout cas quand je vois à quoi ça mène
un handicapé qui a de l'argent moi
j'arrête de donner au Téléthon c'est
je plaisante j'ai jamais donné alors
pistorious a raconté à la barque il a
cru que c'était une intrusion de
domicile ça c'est tout le charme de
l'Afrique du Sud quoi la balle est
voleur sont mannequins et avant de te
cambrioler ils prennent une douche
enfin quand on voit à quoi ressemblait
le cambrioleur ça donne envie de laisser
les clés sur la porte plus souvent
politique alors Véronique Genest se
lance dans la reine alors la déclarer un
truc formidable
je ne suis ni raciste ni xénophobe je
suis agnostique et la séparation de
l'État et de la religion me va bien
une phrase qui est à peu près autant de
sens que de déclarer je ne suis
allergique ni au gluten ni aux huîtres
je prends dans le cul et l'ouverture des
magasins le dimanche ça me convient
[Applaudissements]
Elysée alors opération transparence tout
le monde à poil moi franchement j'aurais
préféré rien savoir vraiment je dirais
Fillon qui a une bicoque dans la Sarthe
du flow in Twingo à 1500 euros Belkacem
un livret A Philippe ETI un appartement
de 70 mètres carrés on demande au
ministre de l'honnêteté pas de faire
pitié
[Applaudissements]
si on continue comme ça même les rhums
voudront plus venir
cinéma il y a une campagne actuellement
d'acteurs contre la surpêche
alors pour attirer l'attention on fait
poser des stars à poil à côté de poisson
et de mollusque ça c'est le grand truc
contemporain pour attirer l'attention
faut se [ __ ] et tu vois Mélanie
Laurent avec un tourteau pour dire il
faut arrêter de vider les réserves de la
mer
ah bon et elle elle fait quoi là le
crabe après la science et croit qu'on va
le ramener en taxi à l'île de Ré
peut-être
[Applaudissements]
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu